for marchello and his wife susannah
afternoon spent with their children and
grandchildren are more of a distraction
than a pleasure these days they're among
the 25,000 Roma living in Sweden and
they're among the five thousand who have
been included in a secret police
registry of Roma without their knowledge
Purdue is oldham salt dough in there
they said it was a registry of criminals
but that would mean all Roma or
criminals me even our children even our
youngest grandchild who is only two
years old she's supposedly a criminal
when she doesn't even know what that is
they talkin elevated 12 years ago Roma
were officially recognized as a minority
in Sweden just like the Sami and the
finished speaking minority but Roma
still have a difficult time susannah
says it's not easy for them to find jobs
it all became default phone and they say
yeah I must say when you apply for a job
you still can't let them know that
you're Roma may just here in Sweden Roma
tend to have names like ticon or Dimitri
or source and it's hard for them to find
a job even now or dat it's not like that
people have to lie and deny being Roma
it shouldn't be like that Romany didn't
sauce gurudwara the secret police
registry of Roma in southern Sweden was
exposed a few weeks ago by a major daily
newspaper it turns out there are only a
few criminals on the list but their
circle of friends and family has also
been carefully listed
that's exactly the argument the Swedish
police is now using to justify its
actions saying that the Roma registry
isn't actually a list of Roma paid to
spinning gear heads the Serious Crime
Squad in the city of Eddie bro he's a
veemon defender of the secret data
collection he says such lists are a
normal part of investigative work and
that it's just a coincidence that only
Roma are listed says it will send on a
micrometer and after people are asking
how it's possible that only Roma are
listed in this registry but for me
that's nothing unusual if you're
investigating a criminal network of Roma
then it's normal that only Roma are
listed we use this data for our
intelligence needs freon athletic and
awesome but Springer can't really
explain why the list includes women and
small children and the country's
integration Minister isn't satisfied
with the explanations the police are
giving to Eric Ian Hawke the registry is
illegal because it's based on ethnicity
are the known for got 950 three weeks
ago if you'd asked me if I believe that
Swedish police had a registry based
purely on ethnicity I'd have said no I
was angry and sad when I found out that
it does exist the Roma have been listed
in such registries in the past it's a
huge setback for integration efforts
though we don't want to use the word
integration since the Roma are a
national minority the videos photos ago
enough that it didn't they've been part
of Swedish society for five centuries it
would hold on them a part of society
that nonetheless has always been on the
fringes especially in rural Sweden in
those picture book Scandinavian
landscapes Roma families have been
shunned and persecuted for centuries
they've never been welcomed here even in
progressive Sweden prejudices run deep
and last for generations mana for
today's warrior and say hi rahta wonders
fans and of the Swedes saw themselves as
the whitest of the whites in Europe and
the whole world by Odin oh the night a
nice unique feeling of racial purity has
led to that doing everything in order to
maintain it and then you'll doubt them
and man you dare utter throat behold
Adam so-called race research was carried
out in Sweden during the last century a
race biology Institute at the University
of Uppsala researched supposed racial
characteristics the university library's
digital archive still has photographs
displaying allegedly typical Roma
characteristics Tobias who Boneta has
studied Sweden's treatment of minorities
he says that much of this racist
ideology lives on today even though the
research is no longer carried out
awesome i'll check it hold on everyone
mayra the authorities have tried to keep
the Roma a separate from the ethnic
Swedes as possible they removed children
from Roma families and started forced
sterilization of Roma they did
everything to keep Roma children out of
schools and away from medical care and
all the other public services that
developed in the Swedish welfare state
in the 20th century we shouldn't forget
that up until the 50s and 60s this group
was deliberately discriminated against
holland Roma have been holding
demonstrations across the country in
recent days they're protesting against
the police registry and against the
discrimination they still face marchello
and his family are now calling for a
special investigation into the matter
they say it should be independent to
prevent the police from covering
anything up who did it often anything we
have to find out the real reason for the
registry how extensive it is and who
else has one we have to make sure these
lists don't exist we have laws
forbidding of them a new herring is
patron dolls typical easily I didn't
trust the police at all anymore I'm
offended and sand and I'm scared or are
they they hadn't yet the job BTW it's
very difficult because we can't feel
safe i need to come on through here it
makes us very sad / in this sun they
point out that sweden has the rule of
law so they hope that one day soon
they'll be able to go to a playground
with their children and grandchildren
and feel like normal
Swedish citizens